hello there Internet I just wanted to
give you a special message outside the
regular body of our show regarding the
FCC at the government agency legally
required to know what bosh is we
actually looked into it and it turns out
that Oscar Bosch gosh
bad boy inventor of OshKosh B'gosh and
it proved me wrong
you can't nobody can you may remember on
last week's episode we talked about the
FCC's plan to undermine net neutrality
regulations by stripping Internet
service providers of their current title
to classification and at the end of our
piece we asked you to reach out to the
FCC we even set up this website to make
it easier to leave a comment and frankly
comment you did go FCC yourself is
trending on Twitter this morning
this comes after last night's John
Oliver from the last week tonight asked
all of us viewers to flood the Federal
Communications Commission to save net
neutrality again
everything about that man's tone is
hugely insulting and let me explain
particularly why
what are you essentially saying there is
John Oliver a comedian you think about
so little you probably didn't even
notice that is not John Oliver that's
Stephen Colbert
[Applause]
mr. Christian the FCC side did get a ton
of comments the number is now up to
around 1.6 million and those those
comments have come from all quarters of
the political spectrum from net
neutrality advocates to those who want
the FCC to rollback oversight of ISPs to
comments like I want to be able to view
my streaming porn without more lag
please don't screw me here lateral
plaintiff face it's all I got
this is already great it's already
tremendous but that that comment also
apparently came from the international
space station which for a start explains
why the smiley face is sideways
emoticons orbiting the Earth are not
bound by gravity that's a science fact
but but on but on the other hand I find
it hard to believe an actual scientist
on board the International Space Station
left that comment because there is no
way anyone up there has any use for porn
and I'll tell you why they are way too
busy space oh yeah they are base
until the Sun comes up up there
which it literally doesn't think about
it it's always night time you're in
cramped quarters with colleagues there's
nothing else to do up there and it's
really easy to be upside down which
according to books can be a sex thing
well plus you've already got the helmets
you know the helmets you wear during sex
and it is undeniably true that some
people tried to mess with the comments
until mr. one conservative writer that
is reason enough to discount all of them
they're calling this grassroots it's
really not anything of the kind it
really looks like astroturf because when
you look at these comments thousands are
using fake names
thousands comments or using John Oliver
they're using Donald Trump they're using
Barack Obama they're using Homer Simpson
Michael Jackson and the rest now in case
you're thinking hold on there Michael
Jackson is actually a very common name I
should tell you that at least one of
them said he lived at four-twenty
butthole Street which which is which is
also as I understand
we common address but you know clearly
clearly she's right some comments on the
site were faked but interestingly many
of those were actually on the other side
of this issue in fact the FCC received
one hundred twenty eight thousand
identical comments which were anti net
neutrality and when journalists reached
out to the supposed commenters they
found several had no knowledge of their
alleged comments so these were almost
certainly spam bots which actually makes
this even stranger because you would
assume that the bots would be in favor
of a free and open Internet how else
would they tell everyone how to earn
sixty five hundred dollars a week
working from home think about all the
readers the comments section of a
Huffington Post article who will miss
out on this amazing opportunity BOTS
think about it bots you should have
thought the issue thrown but you know
questionable authorship was not the only
problem there were also some issues with
content it's not really surprising that
you have a lot of vulgar obscene and
downright racist comments when job
Oliver himself is calling this campaign
go FCC yourself yes I did do that but
you know unfortunately she's right about
something there
there were some racist comments on there
and let me just say if any of those came
from anyone who watches this show stop
it
do not do that writing racist
things on the internet is not how you
win the net neutrality debate it's how
you win the presidency we know that
[Applause]
so my skill to encourage anyone on earth
or indeed above its orbiting the planet
like space care comes to please
comment in a civil clear fashion
although and this is really important
don't actually do it right now because
the FCC is scheduled to vote on their
net neutrality proposal on Thursday May
18th to officially kick off months of
debate but due to a procedural quirk
they will not be considering any
comments submitted in the one week
leading up to the vote so please hold
off for the moment in fact if you go to
go FCC yourself you will see we are no
longer redirecting you to their website
we're sending you to a holding page
where you might be watching this video
right now but when it is okay to comment
again we will send you back to the FCC's
comments page where you can and should
tell FCC Chairman a cheap I feel you
specifically support strong net
neutrality that's by title to oversight
of ISPs so that's it but that's all I
need to say to you until next time I am
apparently Stephen Colbert saying
goodnight